president joe biden is visiting new york
and new jersey today to survey the
damage left behind by last week's storms
at least 50 people were killed when the
remnants of hurricane ida triggered
flash flooding across the northeast the
president declared a major disaster in
several counties across those two states
and that'll allow people to get federal
aid for temporary housing and home
repairs
i could have did cannonballs off my roof
that's how deep the water was the kids
toys is the most heartbreaking you know
because they really don't understand the
magnitude of what happened
now item made landfall down in louisiana
on the gulf coast and there about half a
million people still don't have power so
some are just leaving the state until
the power comes back
any place the lord blesses us to go out
of this heat where we're able to get
some food get a hot bath and just some
comfort
such a struggle for folks down there
right now and it could be weeks before
people in louisiana have power again